lithuania has taken a major step towards
joining the euro area next year at a
meeting in luxembourg eu economics and
finance ministers agreed that the baltic
states met the necessary conditions to
start using the single currency on
january the 1st
lithuania's hopes of becoming the 19th
member of the eurozone could be realised
if the endorsements also given by eu
leaders at this summit on june 27
the ministers also approved an amendment
to stop cross-border companies from
exploiting a tax loophole
the amendment will counter so-called
double non-taxation of corporate groups
involving hybrid loan arrangements
the loophole could enable them to
exploit mismatches between national tax
rules and avoid paying taxes on certain
kinds of profits while the directives
purpose was designed to avoid companies
from suffering from double taxation
on the single market
there are cases and we all know them
where it is being abused by companies to
avoid paying taxes in any member state
in other items on the agenda the
ministers approved recommendations to
help bolster the national reform
programs of 26 eu countries and on the
economic policies of the euro area the
move is part of the european semester
process a cycle that helps eu member
states balance their budgets and improve
their fiscal and economic policies